This is the exact leg workout I followed
for 365 days straight. No skipping. And
it took my legs from looking like this
to this. And in this video, I'll show
you every exercise and every technique
cue that I used. And I'll break down the
science behind why it works so well.
Let's get into it. All year, I kicked
off this leg workout with lying leg
curls. Putting them first was an
absolute gamecher for how my knees feel
when I squat. By doing them first, not
only do you prioritize your hamstrings,
which is a muscle that a lot of bros
neglect, but you also get your knees and
soft tissues nice and warmed up for the
rest of the workout. You may be
surprised at just how much better your
squats will feel when your posterior
chain is slightly activated going into
them. Your glutes will fire better, your
knees will track more smoothly, and you
should be stronger. So, if you've ever
had cranky knees during squats, try
curling first. Now, why did I pick the
lying leg curl over the seated leg curl?
Well, most of you have probably heard me
talk about this study before, which
showed that across 12 weeks, seated leg
curls caused 1.6 times more hamstrings
growth than lying leg curls, which is
true. So, let me explain. First, I do
lying leg curls on one day of the week
and then seated hamstring curls on my
second leg day of the week. Also,
research shows that having exercise
variety is generally better for
developing a muscle more proportionally
across all of its heads. And even though
this study did show better hamstrings
growth with the seated leg curl, there
is another big muscle in your legs
called the sartorius. And it actually
grew better with lying leg curls. And
the sartorius is a really important
muscle for bodybuilding, especially when
you're lean because it's this vertical
muscle that really pops out on your quad
poses. And unlike the hamstrings, which
are more stretched when you're seated,
the sartorius is actually more stretched
when you're lying down. Now, the main
technique difference that I made this
year was doing length and partials at
the end of every last set. So, once I
couldn't get the pad all the way up, I
kept going with partial reps. This works
great because of the strength curve of
the hamstrings. You'll find that as you
get close to failure, you're still
really strong in the bottom half, but
you can't get the weight all the way up.
So, we can leverage that by using
partial reps at the end. Now, the
biggest mistake I see on these is
letting your hips pop up. This will
allow your glutes and low back to help
you cheat the weight up. So instead, you
should think about driving your hips
into the pad as you curl. You can also
grip the handles harder to help pull
yourself into the bench. Remember, you
want everything to be as stable as
possible here so that all that tension
coming from the weight stack is being
sent directly into your hamstrings.
Okay, this is where the real heavy
overloading starts. Three sets of six to
eight reps on the pendulum squat. This
was easily my number one quad builder
for my year-long experiment. And of
course, it's not just for the quads.
Like any squat, it'll also smash the
glutes and the adductor muscles of the
inner thighs. Now, obviously, not every
gym has a pendulum squat machine. So, if
you don't have one, you can swap it out
for another squat variation that you can
progressively overload well, like a
barbell squat, Smith machine squat, or a
hack squat. For barbell squats, you can
make them more quad dominant by placing
the bar higher on your traps and staying
more upright. For Smith machine squats,
you can increase the quad emphasis by
keeping your feet back underneath you
and letting your knees travel forward.
Same for hack squats. Feet back in a
deeper knee angle for quad bias. I
prefer the pendulum, though, because you
not only get low back support like on a
hack squat, but pendulum squats are
notoriously harder at full depth, so you
have to fight more to get out of the
bottom. This gives you a massive growth
stimulus for the quads. I also find the
arcing movement path of a pendulum squat
feels a bit smoother than the linear
movement path of a hack squat. But I'm
kind of splitting hairs now if I'm being
honest. Your quads should feel lit up
even after just one set. And that's
exactly why you don't want to push every
set all the way to failure on these. So
leave one or two reps in the tank for
the first couple sets. This will still
deliver a gigantic quad stimulus without
hurting your performance for the
subsequent sets. Then on the last set, I
really hype myself up and give it
everything I've got. I just tell myself
to keep going up and down until I can't
get up anymore. Then I let the weight
drop on the safety pin. But remember
that with the pendulum squat in
particular, it will feel very hard in
the bottom, especially as you approach
failure. So even if it feels like you
can't get the weight up, keep pushing.
If you can just get through that
sticking point near the bottom, you will
be able to get all the way up and finish
the rep. And you might surprise yourself
with how many extra reps you can get
once you really lock in and give it your
all. And then every couple months,
you'll want to do a D load week where
you strip the weight back. Trust me,
you'll need that if you're pushing your
last set to failure week in and week out
while progressively overloading by
adding a little weight or a rep from
week to week. Now, the most common
mistake I see here is cutting your depth
short. One of the main advantages of the
pendulum squat is that it's very quad
dominant. But if you're not getting deep
enough, your quads are really missing
out on that juicy high tension spot
toward the bottom where torque is the
highest. So bury these as deep as you
can comfortably go. If you're not sure
what your depth looks like, record your
set from the side. You might notice that
you're not going quite as deep as you
thought. Now, when it comes to
hamstrings growth, I do think the tried
andrue Romanian deadlift made the
biggest difference for me this year.
Obviously, a common theme I followed all
year was choosing exercises that I could
add a little weight to from week to
week. So, if you start your program
doing two plates per side for six hard
reps, and you end your program doing
three plates per side for six hard reps,
your glutes and hamstrings will be
bigger. That's just how it works. This
exercise obviously complements our
hamstrings exercise from earlier since
the leg curl trains knee flexion while
the RDL trains hip extension. And those
are the two functions of the hamstrings.
The main cue you want to focus on here
is pushing your glutes straight back.
That keeps the movement a true hip hinge
and prevents you from turning it into a
squat. I also keep a slight knee bend on
these, but don't let my knees drift
forward. Just enough of a bend to keep
stress off my knee joints and keep
tension on the muscle. And I'll say
this, if you've never filmed your RDL's
from the side, you should do it. This
angle will give you the best insight on
your form. As you lift, the bar should
be moving up and down in a straight line
centered over the middle of your foot,
not drifting out to the front. Now, the
most common mistake I see on the
Romanian deadlift is actually
overreaching at the bottom. A lot of
people chase extra range of motion by
collapsing their spine and letting their
back round a lot or by letting the bar
drift too far out in front. Instead, you
want to keep your back tight, keep the
barring close to your body, and only
lower it as far as you comfortably can
while maintaining a neutral spine and
keeping tension on your hamstrings. For
me, I usually stop just below knee
level. And as long as I'm maintaining
that neutral lower back, I can get an
amazing hamstring stretch without
needing to go any lower. Okay, I really
think the best isolation exercise for
the quads is of course the leg
extension. And it complements the
compound pendulum squat that we did
earlier very nicely because it actually
hits the big long rectus feorous head of
the quads harder than any squat
variation will. That's because the
rectus feorous crosses both the hip
joint and the knee joint. though it
actually won't change length much on a
squat because your knees and hips are
both moving. However, on a leg
extension, your hips are fixed, which
means the rectus feorous will actually
stretch and squeeze. And research backs
this up. A 2021 study found that across
5 weeks of training, Smith machine
squats didn't grow the rectus forous,
but leg extensions did. It's also just a
really good finisher exercise for the
quads in my opinion. That locked in
position forces you to really isolate
your quads without relying on your
glutes or lower back at all. And I find
I can really focus on feeling my quads
work with a strong mind muscle
connection in a way that just doesn't
work on a squat because there's too much
going on. And you don't need much volume
here. Just one or two hard sets where
you're fighting for every inch will get
the job done. The main technique
difference that I made this year was
setting the seat back as far as I could
get it. This was shown in a new 2024
study to cause about 170% more quad
growth than the standard upright seat
position. And this may seem like
overkill to some of you, but I also
strap in on these. When you're fighting
for those last few reps, it really does
help to be fully locked into the seat.
So, I pull up on the handles as hard as
I can to keep my glutes firmly planted,
directing all the tension into my quads.
And if you want to take it up another
notch, you can try doing a slow 3-second
eccentric. That isn't because slow
eccentrics are inherently better for
muscle growth, but they will allow you
to get the same quad stimulus with
slightly lighter loads, which might ease
up some of the strain on your knees,
which I needed to do after I injured my
knee during a strength test for the
experiment. You'll be surprised how hard
these hit, even with moderate weight.
Now, the most common mistake I see here
is letting your butt pop up and down.
Whenever that's happening, you're losing
stability on the seat, and you are
losing quad tension. So, keep your hips
down at all costs. I even bought an
airline seat belt extender on Amazon for
about five bucks. And lately, I've
started using that to keep my hips down,
especially if I'm going heavier. Okay.
And I would say out of all the lower
body muscles, the one most responsible
for really making it obvious that you
lift, whether you're a man or a woman,
is the glutes. So, we're going to hop
into some glute isolation work on the
hip abduction machine next. Now, up
until the last month or two, I always
did these leaning forward because
conventional wisdom said that leaning
forward should stretch the glute medius
better. However, I recently started
doing them like this with my hips
extended. And that's because the glute
god himself, Dr. Brett Contrarus, did a
response video to my glute tier list
video where he had this to say. If you
look at the fiber directions of the
glute medius, they're not well aligned
for leaning seated hip abduction.
However, you can just bridge up and do a
hip thrust and then do bridged seated
hip abduction and then you're really
targeting the glute medius, leaning
forward for the glute max, bridged for
the glute me. And since there isn't any
direct research comparing these two
techniques, I think what Brett is saying
makes sense. Plus, I suspect that
switching up your hip angle on these
every now and then is probably better
for overall glute development anyway.
This way, you're guaranteed to be
hitting all the fibers from slightly
different angles. So, since we already
smashed the glute max pretty hard on the
pendulum squad and the RDL, let's do
these with straight extended hips and
really focus on stimulating those upper
glute medius fibers. Now, the biggest
mistake I see here is actually just
going too light and not pushing hard
enough. For whatever reason, a lot of
guys see this as a kind of fluff and
pump exercise and just go through the
motions stopping well shy of failure.
But if you're an intermediate to
advanced lifter, you should absolutely
be maxing out most hip abduction
machines and adding more weight with a
gym pin. Otherwise, you're probably not
pushing yourself hard enough. If you
finish your set and you don't need to
sit still for 10 seconds or so before
popping up and walking away, you
probably didn't go hard enough. Okay?
And at this point in the workout, you'll
probably want to skip calves, but I
promise you that is the main reason
they're not growing. So, find a good
straight leg calf raise that you feel
well and push it hard for eight to 10
reps, emphasizing the deep stretched
part of the range of motion. If calves
are a priority for you, you could even
put them first in the workout so you're
less tempted to skip them. By far the
biggest mistake I see here is not going
deep enough. Most people do these short,
bouncy reps up onto their toes, but we
know from a growing pile of data that a
deep stretch is crucial for forcing new
calf growth. You don't even need to go
all the way up onto your toes either.
Just rotate up and down on the balls of
your feet. And try this. At the end of
your last set, sink into the bottom
stretch position and hold it for 30
seconds. It might feel like your
Achilles tendon is going to snap, but
trust me, it won't. And this stretch
underload stimulus seems to be
especially effective for calf
hypertrophy. Okay, so that's all I'm
going to cover in terms of workouts from
the new program here on the channel. If
you want the full upper lower pushpull
legs routine, you can pick it up over on
jeffnnipper.com. And I'll go ahead and
put a discount code in the description
box below just for YouTube so you can
save 25% off. Also, it's not enough to
just dial your training in. Your diet is
also super important. So, if you pair
the new program with my nutrition app,
MacroFactor, I guarantee you'll make
better gains than you would with just
the training program alone. So, you can
get a twoe free trial of MacroFactor at
the link below. Just use code Jeff when
you download. All right, thanks for
watching, guys. I'll see you all here in
the next